turning now to one of my favorite people
seam Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
is speaking out about the country's
biggest challenges and its strengths
I spoke to Justice Ginsburg last night
in a wide-ranging conversation at the
92nd 92nd Street Y here in New York she
reflected on the reasons for hillary
clinton's loss in the presidential
election when do you think we'll see a
woman as president when do i think
mm-hmm we came pretty close yes you
think sexism played a role in that
campaign I do I think so yes I have no
doubt that it did do you think it was
decisive
it was decisive in other words if
Hillary Clinton had been a man she would
have won that election going away
there's so many things that might have
been decisive but that was a major major
effect factors Ginsburg also said she
worries the country putting basic values
like Liberty at risk because of security
concerns she pointed to diversity as a
great strength and let me just make one
quick point she is now has a great
trainer who's writing a book Bryan
Johnson so she's very much into her
training regime as she is 84 and going
strong this is like physical working out
yes indeed I love it and I love that her
husband makes all her meals for and has
them packed up for her for the week
ahead she's just great he was a great
chef he died in 2010 yeah but a great
man who cooked everything she hadn't
cooked a meal in 18 years yeah what do
you think of that she is incredible